bonsoir bienvenue on est à onze jours du
premier tour c'est ça vous regarde en
direct est désormais chaque soir un
grand débat sur un thème de campagne ce
soir le monde agricole en pleine
tourmente avec la flambée des prix de
l'énergie des céréales et des engrais
comment faire face quand les coûts de
production s'envolent les consommateurs
vont-ils payer la facture et puis quelle
agriculture pour demain à l'heure où la
guerre en ukraine commandes de produire
plus la fnsea faisait passer leur grand
oral au candidat aujourd'hui un maître
mot se dégage la souveraineté
alimentaire on en parle dans un instant
sur ce plateau avec nos invités et au
fait ils demandent quoi les français
notre grand témoin s'est lancé dans une
enquête de grande ampleur avec l'ifop
elle les a sondé sur toute une série de
thèmes la sécurité économie l'hôpital
l'écologie elle publie 2022 les français
ont choisi chez plon l'essayiste et
chroniqueuse par barral le faire est
avec nous ce soir enfin dans le calme ce
soir l'oeil de blacko sur les petits
candidats de gauche comment se
positionne-t-il quand jean-luc mélenchon
martèle que le vote utile c'est lui la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand
s'interroge sur une grande absente
l'écologie dans cette campagne et piasa
monde un gars va revenir sur une
audition importante à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui celle des chefs de la prison
d'armes dans laquelle a été assassiné
yvan colonna voilà pour le menu c'est
parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs un grand débat chaque
soir sur un thème de campagne d'ici au
10 avril ce soir on va parler
agriculture et alimentation
il y a d'abord l'urgence face à la
flambée des prix et puis il ya un nouvel
objectif dans la bouche de quasiment
tous les candidats la souveraineté
alimentaire on va parler des deux ce
soir avec vous daniel sauvaitre bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous est
arboriculteur vous avez des vergers des
pommiers principalement vous présidez
l'association nationale pommes poires et
vous êtes aussi maire de reignac brignac
en charente je le précise il ya
plusieurs reignac
voilà sur notre territoire bonsoir
monsieur brun bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes directeur scientifique de
la fondation farm qui promeut
l'agriculture durable dans le monde
entier et puis bon soir avoue michael
hogan on vous connaissait député la
république en marche et on vous découvre
aujourd'hui directeur général de la nuit
en france association nationale des
industries agroalimentaires
beaucoup d'industriels très connus comme
les enseignes lactalis unilever ferrero
ou encore parce qu'aimer aussi une
multitude de petites pme vous nous direz
comment les industriels regarde ce
marché qui s'affolent emmanuel ducrocq
est en retard vous la connaissez elle
est chroniqueuse dans cette émission
journalistes et l'opinion et spécialiste
des questions liées à l'agriculture à
l'alimentation à nous rejoindre dans un
tout petit instant va partir de de
l'actualité pour commencer je vous le
disais c'est l'inquiétude face à la
flambée des prix des matières premières
le gouvernement a fait déjà quelques
gestes mais ce contexte d'inflation peut
durer au risque même de devoir en france
quelques faillites on voit cela dans le
détail avec alix guillaud je vous donne
la parole juste après
les paysans français sont directement
impactés par la guerre en ukraine toutes
leurs charges augmentent en raison de
l'embargo sur le pétrole russe les
carburants sont plus chers pour faire
rouler leurs tracteurs hausse du prix
également des engrais qui provenaient
essentiellement de russie aujourd'hui la
pénurie fait flamber les cours cet
engrais là cette année
vaut autour donc deux entre 400 et 500
euros et pour l'année prochaine on parle
de cette aune-là passera à peu près à
1000 euros voire au delà et surtout
hausse des prix de près de 30 % de la
nourriture pour le bétail la plus grosse
dépense des éleveurs 50 à 70% de ces
aliments venait d'ukraine là-bas le
bruit des chars russes a remplacé celui
des tracteurs en russie les exportations
sont bloqués par les sanctions résultat
les greniers à céréales du monde sont à
l'arrêt huile de tournesol maïs et
surtout blé la russie était le premier
exportateur mondial l'ukraine le
quatrième avant la guerre il assurait à
eux seuls 30 % du commerce mondial
alors forcément les cours explose
dépassant 450 euros la tonne contre 120
il y a à peine deux ans la gare en
ukraine pourrait provoquer des famines
en afrique notamment en egypte très
dépendante du blé russe et ukrainien
alors doit-on craindre une pénurie chez
nous pas selon le ministre de
l'agriculture la france est totalement
indépendant souverain dans sa production
de céréales est insuffisante pas tolérer
aucun risque de pénurie pas de pénurie
certes mais une augmentation du prix du
panier moyen dans les rayons du
supermarché la guerre et ses
conséquences sur l'agriculture en europe
et en france devrait faire bondir les
prix de l'huile de tournesol de la
volaille du porc et du boeuf et par
ricochet du lait du beurre de la crème
et des oeufs
voilà j'essaie de l'arrivée d'emmanuel
ducrocq bienvenue à emmanuel je vais
commencer avec vous daniel sauvaitre
évidemment on a envie de vous demander
comment vous vivez ça vous
personnellement dans vos verger on se
dit que peut-être vous êtes un peu moins
frappés par l'ensemble des matières
premières dont peut-être vous l'avez pas
moins d'usagers par rapport à un éleveur
par exemple qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous lisez concrètement en fait c'est
pas aussi puissant que pour les éleveurs
mais la hausse des matières premières à
commencer dès l'automne dernier puisque
le carton a pris
25% au mois de novembre et bien l'europe
pour soins dont certains villages les
emballages augmenté de 40% donc c'est
karine hausse spectaculaire
on a là aussi évidemment des l'énergie
on a le hausse des carburants et puis on
a eu également une hausse ou bien
biologique des salaires donc on a quand
même une hausse assez significative et
puis évidemment on commence la nouvelle
saison on va avoir des hausses pour les
pour les engrais on aime aussi pour les
produits phytosanitaires on a même un
problème de disponibilité de certaines
matières actives que nos collègues
européens peuvent utiliser voyez on est
dans une situation qui va être
différente de celle que l'on vient de
décrire pour les éleveurs
mais c'est en train de se tendre et la
particularité c'est qu'on a évoqué la
hausse des prix pour les consommateurs
nous sommes dans une situation
différente c'est à dire que la
consommation des fruits légumes y
compris les pommes a plutôt baissé
depuis le mois de novembre alors qu'elle
était plutôt très bonne pendant locaux
vides
on a un peu de difficulté à mettre de la
difficulté à maintenir les prix qui
n'étaient pas mauvais mais on considère
que la hausse des coûts de revient et
d'au moins 10 de 10 centimes en semant
du kilo et donc pour la fin de saison ça
va se tendre ce match car agissez on a
fait le point avec les collègues
producteurs on a une présence de plus en
plus important que ça se comprend aussi
dans nos collègues polonais qui nous
envoient des pommes à moitié prix de
celles que et on a vu des opérateurs qui
disent qu'il y à des acheteurs pour ses
pommes à bas prix emmanuel vous qui
prenez la température quasi
quotidiennement du monde agricole cette
crise liée à la flambée des prix
quel est l'état d'esprit des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire où est le niveau d'
alerte est ce que c'est certains
secteurs sont plus exposées que d'autres
est ce que certains craignent même de de
fermer la porte alors je dirais que le
monde agricole est partagé entre trois
sentiments d'abord il ya une grande
solidarité avec leurs confrères
ukrainiens se sont demandés s'ils ont
beaucoup de clients historiques parce
qu'il ya eu des visites de part et
d'autre et c'est donc ils ont tous des
histoires de collègues ukrainiens
raconté donc ça c'est une chose qui est
qui est frappante et il se soucie
beaucoup de la souveraineté alimentaire
et de l'alimentation en ukraine ça ils
sont pas centrés sur eux-mêmes yahia
cette préoccupation qui est globale donc
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est qu'ils sont conscients que
les lie à un moment historique pour
l'agriculture française on est en train
de se rendre compte qu'on a sans doute
sa beauté dépend de notre souveraineté
qu'ils ont alerté dans le désert et qu'
il va falloir probablement raccrocher
les wagons et que c'est pas facile parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'opposition donc à
une attitude qui est un peu disons le
pied de guerre les agriculteurs ont
conscience que les choses vont changer
probablement qu'il va falloir qu'il
réponde présent qu'on est à un tournant
plusieurs sur l'urgence sur la leur sur
bébé mario juste parce que parce que ces
choses-là s'interpénètrent et vous
voulez comprendre et sur l'urgence quand
on discute par exemple je les fais au
salon de l'agriculture avec les
producteurs de porcs de volailles oeufs
sont extrêmement inquiets les prix des
aliments avait commencé à flamber pour
pour les porcs et les volailles avant
l'invasion de l'ukraine il faut savoir
que pour une volaille le coût de
l'alimentation dans toute sa vie c'est à
peu près 65 % de son coût donc c'est
énorme et quand cette alimentation à
prix 100 200 % ce ça change complètement
l'équation économique des fermes donc
pour les fermes de porcs qui ont déjà eu
un plan de soutien gouvernemental parce
que ça allait vraiment pas très bien
avant l'invasion en ukraine pour la
filière volaille c'est très compliqué ça
allait probablement un peu moins pour la
filière bovine parce que c'est une
filière qui a beaucoup développé ces
approvisionnements locaux les animaux
nous mangent de l'herbe et puis des
produits de la ferme donc ça limite la
casse disons mais effectivement tout ce
qui dépend d'intrants qui viennent de
l'extérieur pour la ii les intrants
cette touche malheureusement a besoin et
puis notre l'agriculture qu'on importe
qui vient dans un temps suivant c'est
celui de la prochaine campagne on a une
grosse inquiétude sur la disponibilité
des engrais alors je rappelle qu'on met
pas des engrais pour faire joli dans les
champs la moitié de la population
mondiale dépend des engrais pour se
nourrir on fait pas du bon blé
panifiable sans engrais jeanjean globe
tous les engrais qui soit organique ou
pas mais les engrais organiques on en a
pas assez pour la demande épicer un peu
moins efficace donc en fait il ya aussi
ça les engrais ça vient de russie les
prix ont littéralement flambé ils ont
été multiplié par quatre par 6 on sait
même pas exactement et on sait pas si
l'année prochaine on en aura en quantité
suffisante pour les récoltes voilà un
peu le panorama global que je peux faire
maintenant match après il ya une
question aussi sur la durée de la crise
et de cette inflation pour pour toutes
les matières premières que les
agriculteurs utilisent est-ce que vous
avez la pression au fond que la réponse
est à la hauteur il ya quelques quelques
gestes de soutien notamment pour faire
contenir ses coûts de production et puis
est-ce que vous avez sentiment aussi que
il va y avoir de la casse où il faut
attendre je pense que d'abord pour
réagir aux propos d'emmanuel il faut
avoir une vision monter d'un étage et
regarder ce qui se passe au niveau
international aussi puisqu'on parle de
france autour de la table aujourd'hui
mais cette flambée des cours des
matières premières agricoles elle se
fait en tout cas pour la france dans un
pays où on a des soutiens où on a des
agriculteurs et des agricultrices qui
ont une bonne campagne cette année par
contre au niveau international un
contexte de flambée des prix
internationaux qui est extrêmement
préoccupant moment historique c'est vrai
parce que les prix des matières
premières agricoles de denrées de base
comme le blé le sucre le lait les oeufs
augmente partout sur la planète et quand
un estomac afin qu est ce qu il fait ils
se révoltent rip avoir de l'instabilité
politique mode canine et prononcez le
lot divine été prononcé
et les pays méditerranéens sont les
premiers exposés la réponse elle doit
être avant tout une réponse politique et
économique mes collègues le rac le
rappellerons beaucoup mieux que moi
effectivement l'enjeu de produire plus
il est il est sur la table mais l'enjeu
d'avoir accès à cette nourriture il est
absolument essentiel donc là je devrais
me placer un peu du côté du consommateur
parce que les premiers impactés vont
être ceux qui sont dans des situations
de précarité alimentaire en egypte au
bénin
de solidarité humanitaire exige la
transparence sur les productions
notamment chinoises vous y croyez
franchement alors la question des
souverainetés des enjeux politiques et
géopolitiques ça fait quelques années
qu'on le rappelle mais c'est aujourd'hui
en fait on le prend en pleine face parce
que on est devant une crise qui pourrait
être absolument impactante sur
l'ensemble de la population mais si on
revient sur la france les premières
personnes qui seront exposées à 7 cette
hausse des prix ce sont les les gens qui
sont en grande précarité ou en moyenne
précarité parce que les plus fragiles
parce que les prix vont augmenter
parfois sur les prix premium les
problèmes les premiers prix et donc ces
personnes là qui vont être le plus
exposé à cette flambée des bas on va
discuter de ça parce que les idées on va
voir si c'est possible pas de chèques
alimentaires sous conditions de qualité
d'alimentation michael nogal qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire est ce que est ce que
l'agriculteur très impactées peut se
dire je répercute après tout je
répercute sur le prix de vente est ce
que c'est possible ça est-ce que vous
industriel vous le comprendrez dans quel
secteur est-ce que vous êtes prêts et
beaucoup de questions mais faut qu'on
aille vite à faire des efforts pour que
in fine et se soit pas le consommateur
qui paye la facture d'abord on le
comprend dans le soutien essayé
totalement l'objet de la loi et galine 2
vous savez cette loi qui permet de
sanctuariser la rémunération des
agriculteurs dans la relation entre avec
une efficacité
derrière des distributeurs la difficulté
par rapport à ce qui a été dit depuis
depuis tout à l'heure c'est que on avait
déjà en 2021 une hausse des coûts qui me
commence à se voir parce que vous avez
dans le monde entier en fait d des
entreprises qui sollicitent les mêmes
matières premières les mêmes entre
industriels qui sollicitent les mêmes
premières matières premières agricoles
est donc cette année 2021 déjà difficile
pour les entreprises on a attaqué les
négociations commerciales avec la
distribution avec des tarifs qui n'ont
pas été totalement débat sur le gâteau
aujourd'hui vous avez vous avez la
guerre en ukraine plus la grippe aviaire
je veux penser à tous les producteurs de
volailles c'est un impact sur la
volaille c'est un impact sur les poules
pondeuses donc sur les d eux que vous
retrouvez dans beaucoup d'aliments
aujourd'hui est donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'on nous dit c'est que la chaîne
alimentaire doit être solidaire on y
prend notre part qu'on l'a sûrement
nation juste rémunération quand ça veut
dire qu'on accepte les prix que nous
demande des agriculteurs ça c'est
sanctuarisé grâce à la loi et
aujourd'hui ce qu'il n'a pas été
sanctuarisé par la loi c'est tous des
intrants industriels les emballages le
carburant l'énergie le gaz et
l'électricité on n'a pas encore parlé
mais ça a un impact énorme et l'ont
énormément les entreprises je disais
tout à l'heure l'ania ses seize mille
entreprises 98% de tpm qui à la
visibilité aujourd'hui dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois personne et c'est cette difficulté
qu'on a avec des discussions qui vont se
poursuivre demain avec le ministre de
normandie et la ministre en espagnol une
hache et pour discuter avec la filière
amont agricole avec l'affairé ne soit
avec les agriculteurs les fournisseurs
comme nous comme l'ania et puis
attributions vous reçoit toutes les
semaines au ministère
je veux saluer vraiment julien normandie
veux saluer cette initiative qui a été
prise par le par le gouvernement conques
on a des sous les traits à négocier vous
êtes prêt à faire des gestes pour que je
pense qu'il y aurait scène alimentaire
je pense qu'on pourra annoncer des
bonnes nouvelles demain puisque tout le
monde est solidaire dans cette chaîne
alimentaire de la manche comme je le
disais jusqu'à la distribution au client
final ministre lui-même
le ministre et puis l'ensemble des
cendres le des acteurs de la chaîne
alimentaire
solidarité qui s'exprime mais croyez pas
la ratifier envol quand même parce que
dans pour les frais légumes frais comme
ajouté tout à l'heure la formation du
prix elle se fait réellement par l'offre
et la demande est aujourd'hui bien que
nous prix de revient augmente compte
tenu du marché qui est difficile et puis
encore de la concurrence je vous disais
tout à l'heure que aujourd'hui on a des
pommes qui peuvent s'acheter à moitié
prix que celle dont il est extrêmement
difficile de revendiquer
alimentaire pour les fruits et légumes
frais c'est le marché le marché le
marché le marché bien entendu nous
allons voir nos nos acheteurs pour leur
dire écoute mes prix augmentent
j'aimerais que tu m'accepte une petite
augmentation mais ça n'est pas comme ça
que ça se passait en fonction du marché
point important c'est que le
gouvernement assume l'inflation ça c'est
assez nouveau par rapport aux dernières
semaines et ça c'est de nature a profité
à l'ensemble de la filière c'est à dire
que les agriculteurs vont pas qu'on
pense compenser et vont pouvoir
répercuter les coûts les agriculteurs
sur les industriels et nous ce qu'on
discute en ce moment aussi avec la
distribution c'est la capacité de tout
le monde à part à partager les surcoûts
qui nous sont imposées puisque cette
situation en réalité personne ne la
souhaitait et personne ne l'avait
envisagé encore deux mois emmanuel avant
de voir ce compte il est les différents
candidats à besançon congrès de la fnsea
je crois que vous avez tous suivi de
très près est ce qu'on peut parler de ce
chèque alimentaires ont parlé des plus
fragiles alors évidemment il ya ceux qui
sont directement impactés dans certains
pays du maghreb mais aussi en france les
plus fragiles ont leur première chèque
est ce que vous avez des éléments
précision là dessus c'est combien
d'euros par semaine par mois et en
contrepartie de quoi alors ça c'est très
difficile à dire alors je vous lire que
dans les pays du maghreb il y avait
jusqu'à maintenant des chambres de
compensation sur les prix du blé où
l'état prenait à sa charge une partie
des surcoûts mais elles sont
complètement débordés donc nous on est
dans un autre genre de mécanisme mais ça
existe ailleurs mais ça va trouver ses
limites ça c'était pour revenir sur ce
que disait mathieu sur la disponibilité
des produits ailleurs dans le monde et
notamment dans le bassin méditerranéen
alors en france après le confinement les
associations humanitaires alertés sur le
fait qu'on avait à peu près 8 millions
de nos concitoyens qui avait fait appel
à l'aide alimentaire pendant les
confinements donc ce sont des gens qui
sont dans des situations de fragilité et
qui vont prendre cette inflation en
pleine face parce qu'ils étaient déjà à
quelques euros près pour terminer le
mois comment les biens de première
nécessité - qui risque de devenir donc
là ce sont des familles notamment
monoparentales des gens qui sont
éloignés de l'emploi ou simplement
qu'ils sont des travailleurs pauvres et
précaires qui vont vraiment avoir du mal
à se nourrir donc c'est à ces gens là
qu'il faut penser quand on pense chèques
alimentaires alors après c'est un sujet
qui fait relativement l'unanimité dans
la classe politique tout le monde est
assez d'accord pour l'idée de ce chaque
alimentaire après tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord sur la manière dont on
l'articulent qu'est ce qu'on met dans ce
chèque alimentaires alors est ce vers
quoi on se dirige est-ce qu'on choisi de
subventionner une partie des produits
alimentaires seront à l'aube alors après
il ya des mécanismes européens qui sont
assez stricts et qui ne permettent pas
forcément de le faire donc pas fléché
une aide publique en matière
d'alimentation pas sur des critères
locaux en tout cas pas de cette façon-là
donc est ce que ça veut dire peut-être
qu'il faut réfléchir à d'autres
mécanismes baisser la tva sur certains
produits et c est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut que ça passe par les
épiceries solidaires par exemple c'est
une autre piste et qui va contrôler et
qui va condamner jean et qui a le droit
ou chèque est ce qu'on le fait d'une
manière générale pour tous les foyers s
comment est-ce qu'on cible est-ce qu'on
passe par exemple par les comités
d'action sociaux il ya eu plusieurs
réflexions notamment le du député
mahjoubi sur cette question du chèque
alimentaire puis les personnes elles
mêmes doivent accepter que l'examen oui
au chèque mais pour acheter des produits
plus chers alors c'est pas évident ça
non plus oui c'est aussi une manière de
quand même contrôler la façon dont les
gens consomment ce qui avait un autre
problème de liberté publique alors par
exemple les syndicats agricoles disent
il faut réserver sa aux produits frais
qui sont ceux qui sont le plus difficile
d'accès pour les ménages en difficulté
les fruits et légumes la viande fraîche
les fromages etc alors c'est possible
comment est-ce qu'on comment dire là on
a affaire à des produits qui sont pas
normés qui sont pas des produits avec
des emballages qu'on trouve en grande
distribution si vous savez si vous
voulez donc c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de mettre en place le système
est alors je voulais juste revenir sur
une proposition qui m'a paru
intéressante qui a fait le candidat
gens-là ça alors je vous mets sur ce
point là précisément il proposait la
création d'un ticket paysans sur le même
modèle que le ticket restaurant qui
aurait l avantage de contourner un peu
tout les tous les obstacles et qui
servirait à payer sur les marchés par
exemple donc ça c'est une solution assez
intéressant pour rapprocher des gens des
produits frais avec une aide qui soit
vente de tickets restaurant mais pour le
marché on le marché proximo les voir
chez proxim intéressant alors justement
je suis pas sûr qu'on le sujet que vous
allez voir mentionner cette proposition
de jean la phase qui est sûr c'est que
face à toutes ces dépendances là le
grand chantier la grande question de la
souveraineté alimentaire et bien
redevient une priorité tous les
candidats ou presque en ont parlé
regarder ce sujet signé nicolas coadou
six candidats à la magistrature suprême
en opération séduction merci réel
plaisir de me trouver ici je sais que le
pays vous dois beaucoup face à un
parterre de représentants du monde
agricole le seul candidat de gauche
présents fabien roussel produit une
mesure forte cinq cent mille
agriculteurs en france pour 2030 mais je
dis que c'est le socle minimum pour
relever le défi alimentaire comme le
défi agro écologiques cela suppose
d'installer entre 20 à 25 mille
agriculteurs agricultrices par an c'est
un effort gigantesque
même son de cloche pour le président
sortant et candidat emmanuel macron lui
souhaite installer 20 mille agriculteurs
chaque année du côté de marine le pen
plus qu'un mot un mantra basse et la
souveraineté de notre pays souverain
cette souveraineté souveraineté
alimentaire souveraineté tout court la
candidate du rassemblement national
entend sortir l'agriculture des traités
de libre échange européen et privilégier
les circuits courts en france ce pays de
cocagne que nous ont légué nos anciens
peut nourrir sans problème sa propre
population une pro position partagée par
eric zemmour qui souhaitent même créé
une taxe carbone aux frontières
européennes
les autres pays n'ont pas non normes et
produisent bien souvent dans des
conditions déplorables tout en exportant
massivement vers la france créant ainsi
les conditions d'une concurrence
déloyale impossible à vivre pour vous
enfin jean lassalle le candidat
autoproclamé du monde rural venu face à
un public acquis à sa cause alors j'ai
dix minutes ou est-ce qu'il est le
minuteur sur votre droite il est ce
retour à nous promet d'interrompre toute
négociation des traités de libre échange
et de lancer un plan de 3 milliards
d'euros pour l'agriculture voilà il ya
beaucoup de choses aux traits qu'on
revienne sur ce concept de souveraineté
alimentaire matthieu brasse et c'est
quoi précisément de quoi parle-t-on
savent lire cessé d'importer toute
alimentation de l'étranger c'est ça
depuis l'éclatement de la pandémie on
entend parler de plein de forme de
souveraineté très différentes mais
j'aime sans que personne n'ait vraiment
d'accord sur ce qu'on met d'ailleurs le
mot souveraineté beaucoup le voient
comme un copain comme comme un synonyme
d'autonomie c'est à dire de ne dépendre
que de soi ou que de son proche village
où deux sont proches départements d'être
recentrer uniquement sur soi d'être
autonome en tout sauf qu'on sait très
bien que c'est absolument impossible la
souveraineté c'est pas ça la
souveraineté c'est du politique il faut
pas confondre l'agronomie la production
agricole et le politique la souveraineté
c'est le fait de pouvoir décider d'avoir
la capacité de ceux de choisir aussi ses
dépendances parce que on peut pas pro 3
hir et non pas de se déprendre
totalement absolument ces sas avoir
conscience de ses dépendances parce que
on est dans un monde qui est
interdépendant depuis l'antiquité en
échange les romains aller chercher du
lait de l'autre côté de la méditerranée
a pas de raison qu'on arrête d'échangés
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas de sens en tout
cas de mort à plus de café ni temps au
chocolat ou de chocolatines donc ça n'a
pas de sens de réfléchir à se replier
sur soi et c'est même au contraire très
dangereux quand même le mot de
nationalisme alimentaire dans le débat
présidentiel exactement c'est la
prochaine étape en fait une forme de
politique du ventre de localisme poussé
à l'excès qui a pu me sens à exclure
plutôt qu à inclure quand on mange on
est ensemble on est heureux et c'est 100
pc inclure le maximum de personnes
autour de la table en même temps daniel
sauvaitre suis sûr que vous connaissez à
l'allégorie de la ratatouille quand on
regarde les ingrédients nécessaires pour
faire une ratatouille on est édifié
tomates aubergines courgettes poivrons
oignons façade épandez goût
700 millions d'euros de déficit sur les
légumes de la ratatouille ça veut dire
très clairement aujourd'hui on importe
la ratatouille plus que enfin après
c'est ça plus qu'on est capable de la
fabriquer chez nous comment on en est
arrivé là pour les fruits et légumes
frais on est à 50 % des importations un
peu plus pour les fruits puisqu'on est à
60% d'importation pour les fruits pour
40% de production nationale et pour les
légumes c'est un peu moins on est à 40
66 la version agricoles ont doublé en 20
ans en fait on a perdu à peu près 20
points d'autonomie entre 2000 et 2022 on
était à 70 % d'autonomie on n'est plus
qu'à 50 essais en train de s'aggraver
alors que franchement alors il ya le
choix des consommateurs qui ont le goût
de l'exotisme qui veulent acheter des
fruits qu'ils soient tous à dire qu'en
france la tomate mais la tomate et la
tomate on vient en plus en ce moment on
a avec le coût de l'énergie le fait que
la production des tomates soit très
gourmande en énergie au début eh bien ça
ça coûte beaucoup plus cher et donc ça
donne le privilège aux zones où le
soleil rempli cette fonction donc on est
toujours avec experts comme vous de ce
dossier on se dit quand même c'est ce
qui est plus facile à regarder locales
et bien sûr il faut que les
consommateurs nous aide mais il n'ya pas
que les consommateurs parce que les
consommateurs ils ont vraiment un
attachement à la production nationale on
le voit d'ailleurs c'est pour cette
raison qu'on arrive à tenir certaines
productions alors que nos coûts de
revient sont plus élevés que ce que nous
importons mais on a besoin aussi
peut-être que les pouvoirs publics aient
envie de nous aider et nous aider pas
simplement avec de l'argent nous aider
par les réglementations vous savez on a
le choix national de se tirer des balles
dans le pied en disant vous n'aurez pas
droit ça vous n'aurez pas droit à ça en
france et mes collègues et alimentation
notation européenne oui oui c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous demandons à voir le
socle européen c'est-à-dire que nous
ayons
jamais connue voilà mais il ya quand
même de choix national bon
un collègue l'a qui était un ancien
député bon il faudrait que l'assemblée
nationale était calme assez vives pour
incrémenté les réglementations et faire
de la france on nous dit que nous devons
être le phare du monde et que les autres
suivront ce que nous constatons c'est
que nous avons des difficultés à
produire et que nos collègues en profite
pour nous prendre des parts de marché
souscrit au différend qui vient d'être
retenu c'est vrai que on a la fâcheuse
tendance en france à sûr transposer
c'est à dire ajouter des règles au cadre
européen et se mettre de s'imposer nous
mêmes des contraintes pour la france
mais je j'ai bien aimé le le concept de
choisir versus subir en fait c'est ça la
souveraineté c est ce qu on est en
capacité sur l'ensemble des matières
premières agricoles sur l'ensemble des
produits et ont nourri les français
suffire c'est quand même la base où vous
rendez compte que quand il ya des crises
qui arrive aujourd'hui c'est un conflit
armé aux portes de l'europe où que ce
soit des carmes concrètement qu'ils ont
choisi des crises au
rayon on utilise beaucoup ce mot mais
c'est quoi c'est la capacité à ne pas
subir quand il ya une crise qui s'impose
à vous parce que là aussi personne ne
peut prévoir que dans cinq ans dans dix
ans il se passera à telle ou telle crise
il faut être préparé à ça être préparé à
ça c'est ça la souveraineté c'est ça
qu'on est en train de construire est
pour moi la réponse j'utilisais le mot
tout à l'heure mais c'est la solidarité
aussi elle veut dire que celui des
retraites
oui aujourd'hui un cadre européen qui
est contraignant on voit bien que les
capacités de production elles doivent
augmenter parce que la suit l'arrêt
qu'il faut revenir sur ces quatre la
solidarité du continent européen il se
fait aussi avec nos voisins africains on
voit que par exemple et le ministre de
normandie le disais on est indépendant
sur le plan par exemple la production de
céréales et de blé c'est pas le cas du
maghreb ou c'est pas le code des pays
d'afrique du nord pénurie sur le blé
mais on a vu les dépendances ou en tout
cas c'est la balance commerciale on est
excédentaire dans l'amont agricole grâce
au vin et j'ai vu et aux céréales et aux
blés événements pour le reste on importe
on importe on apporte des choses qu'on
pourrait totalement cultivé en france
par rapport aux réglementations et
notamment aux stratégies européennes
la stratégie
européenne femmes tout forte la
neutralité carbone en 2050 c'est 25%
d'agriculture bio s'est baissé de moitié
les pesticides c'est baisser de 10% les
surfaces cultivées est ce que dans le
contexte actuel sachant qu'on parle de
souveraineté alimentaire c'est
compatible alors je crois qu'il faut
vraiment reprendre à la base cette idée
de farm to fork l'idée qu'on doit avoir
une agriculture avec un impact moindre
qui soit meilleur sur les sujets carbone
et moins gourmandes en intrants c'est
une idée partagée par tous et je pense
que là dessus tout le monde est d'accord
et personne ne demande à ce qu'on a ce
qu'on abaisse les objectifs d'une
agriculture plus vertueuse la nôtre
l'est déjà beaucoup mais elle peut
l'être mieux ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'en revanche la commission a donné des
objectifs qui ont été faits sur un coin
de table c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
modéliser ce que signifier ses objectifs
on appris des chiffres 50% de pesticides
en moins c'est super mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire exactement on met pas des
pesticides sur les cultures pour faire
joli mais parce qu'on a nécessité de
produire alors il faut se poser la
question ce qui n'a pas été fait des
outils pour produire comment est ce
qu'on fait pour réduire les pesticides
on ne peut le faire qu'avec de la
recherche avec accepter des nouvelles
mandé nouveau mode de sélection des
variétés pour avoir des variétés qu'ils
soient résistantes aux maladies par
exemple c'est l'agroécologie gc ca
l'agroécologie ça veut tout dire et ça
veut rien dire quand vous dites
agroécologie les écologistes entendent
écologistes et caen et les agriculteurs
à entendre agriculture l'agroécologie
c'est un chemin ça n'est pas une ça
n'est pas un 1 1 un but ça ne veut rien
dire le but ça doit être de nourrir les
gens de la meilleure manière possible
mais dans ce moment qu'on traverse
sachant qu'il va falloir produire plus
assez il l'a dit le ministre mais ça
c'est pour le blé pour les pays qui en
ont besoin est ce qu'on a besoin de
produits pour le louis d'autres cultures
sachant qu'on parle de souveraineté
alimentaire et ça devient l'objectif on
a besoin de produire plus de fruits de
légumes
au besoin de produire plus de blé ou de
céréales pour nourrir le monde parce que
la france n'a plus une capacité c'est
pas la question de savoir si la france
va nourrir le monde le monde peut
essayer de se nourrir lui-même par
contre c'est vrai que nos amis égyptiens
algériens ou marocains structurellement
ne pourront pas produire plus de blé
donc on doit garder cette capacité
d'exporter pour sécuriser les
approvisionnements alimentaires et pour
pas que la planète dépendent pour près
de 40% de la stratégie de bannir poutine
d'un abord quand même produire plus
d'être absolument indépendant mais de
quoi en fait la question est de savoir
si le diable est dans les détails il
faut qu'on ait le temps d'aller un peu
plus dans les détails les dires de
s'asseoir sur les mesures en interne
parce que l'environnement comme l'a dit
emmanuel c'est pas une fin en soi c'est
un moyen c'est un moyen de cultiver la
résilience des territoires des sols des
écosystèmes de la biodiversité donc
c'est dans cette trajectoire là qu'il
faut s'inscrire et d'ailleurs si je peux
me permettre il faut aussi accompagner
économiquement les pays qui ont besoin
de l'être sur le plan de la production
agricole je pense aux pays d'afrique
subsaharienne on peut accompagner les
agriculteurs construire des filières et
pas uniquement penser en terme de
produire plus pour les autres
on a quand même on peut quand même
identifié pour répondre à votre question
plus précisément des grandes zones de
dépendance auquel on peut remédier je
pense par exemple aux protéines
végétales c'est ce qui est en train de
nous exploser au nez une partie de
l'alimentation notre de nos ports de nos
volailles etc
dépendu des tourteaux de tournesol
ukrainiens ou des tourteaux de soja
brésilien ce qui est quand même une
aberration c'est quand même une des
cultures on voudrait pas faire ici qui
deforest vont dépendre en partie de ça
en partie ses limites alimentation
animale dont on peut ça il ya le passé
ça il ya une partie des choses qu'on
peut réintégrer ici sur les jachères
sans nuire au but principal des jachères
parce que ce sont des cultures un jour
d'expliquer on le dit qu'il faut laisser
un peu comment dire la terre repose et
etc on fait de la jachère si on fait de
la jachère avec par exemple des
oléoprotéagineux on réintègre de la zot
dans le sol ce sont des cultures qui
sont très peu gourmande en pesticides en
engrais n'ont quasiment pas besoin donc
on peut utiliser la terre pour faire par
exemple je sais pas des pois
protéagineux qu'on peut donner aux
animaux qui peuvent servir à faire de la
nourriture on arrête une partie de nos
dépendances à l'ukraine par exemple sans
saboter nos objectifs environnementaux
là on peut faire du même produit celui
que j'aime mieux voilà après il faut se
poser la question de l'opportunité de
promouvoir 25 % de surfaces en bio
j'explique ça ne veut pas forcément dire
que c'est mieux environnants
environnementalement parlant on utilise
quand même des pesticides en bio et en
grande quantité et on divise souvent les
rendement par deux dans le contexte
actuel et on a en plus des prix qui
augmentent de 20 30 40 50% dans le
contexte actuel où on a un manque de
ressources à l'échelle planétaire des
dépendances qui se creuse ici un pouvoir
d'achat sous pression avec une inflation
galopante
est-ce que c'est très pertinent de
promouvoir un modèle d'alimentation
extrêmement élitiste et que 70% des
européens ne peuvent pas se permettre ça
veut pas dire qu'on doit faire une une
agriculture salle ça veut simplement
dire que le bio n'est pas la seule voie
pour faire une agriculture vertueuse il
ya d'autres manières d'y arriver daniel
sauvaitre jeu complet et on dirait
madame en fait la culture bio de ses
consomme beaucoup d'énergie puisque
évidemment il faut retourner la terre il
faut travailler plus donc quelque part
c'est pas c'est pas la solution idéale
il faut regarder les choses de manière
objective que ce soit la production bio
ou la production autres il faut le
regarder avec le quand vous voyez nos
nouveaux objectifs
davantage de d'indépendance quand on
voit les échéances 2050 tous ces
objectifs de réduction on va dire de
tout ce qui est polluant est-ce que
c'est compatible ou est ce qu'à un
moment donné il va y avoir une sorte de
cercle vicieux qui fait qu'on va moins
produire mais pour plus importer des
mauvaises choses pour les thérapies
simplement rappelle emmanuel en fait la
france doit être à l'optimum de ce
qu'elle peut produire tout en respectant
des objectifs environnementaux et comme
l'a dit mathieu et bien évidemment il
faut choisir ce qui irrite air de
produire c'est ça et pour être à
l'optimum évidemment il ne faut pas
raisonner comme je l'entends avec 50%
des actions de pesticides mais il faut
mettre aussi peu de pesticides que
possible tout en maîtrisant les maladies
et ravageurs en fait notre objectif
c'est de réduire la dépendance aux
maladies et ravageurs ça n'est pas de
réduire c'est pas une à bac en disant 50
% de produits phytosanitaires ça ne veut
rien dire
voilà c'est un monde en mutation avec
des objectifs assez élevés tenable ou
pas mais pour revenir à votre question
sur la souveraineté alimentaire la
souveraineté alimentaire elle passera
aussi par une industrie forte je cite
christiane lambert la prison de la fête
nationale les agriculteurs ont besoin
pour vivre décemment aussi pour
continuer à produire pour continuer à
être les meilleurs il faut qu'on soit
fiers de notre alimentation ils ont
besoin d'une industrie forte si les
différents maillons de cette chaîne
alimentaire sont fragilisés avec cette
crise c'est en fait cette souveraineté
alimentaire française mais cette
expertise est ce leadership dans le
monde qui aura du mal à se reconstruire
merci beaucoup c'était passionnant j'ai
appris plein de choses personnellement
merci à vous et peut-être bientôt parce
qu'on sent bien que ce chantier est
ouvert on va s'intéresser maintenant aux
attentes des français le monde agricole
en fait partie mais les céistes barbara
lefebvre sinon vous allez voir une très
vaste enquête avec l'ifop chez flon ça
s'appelle 2022 les français ont choisi
sécurité dépenses publiques santé
économie à la sonde et de manière très
concrète un panel représentatif de plus
de 1000 français pour la présidentielle
et il dessine tous en quelque sorte leur
programme idéal avant de l'accueillir
regarder ces sujets de marco bost mais
si on vous invite barbara lefebvre c'est
parce qu'en pleine campagne
présidentielle
nous avons besoin de votre éclairage sur
ce que veulent les français s'attendent
bien dans votre dernier livre vous les
avez sondés en collaboration avec l'ifop
une enquête qui se désintéressent des
candidats eux multiplient les
propositions pour convaincre nous devons
sortir du nucléaire je veux augmenter de
10% les salaires nets de tous les
français et je souhaite qu'on puisse
mettre en place ce que j'appellerais la
solidarité
climatique basera sur les ménages les
plus aisés barbara lefebvre vous êtes
essayiste éditorialiste dans vos livres
vous vous intéressez à l'antisémitisme
au rôle de l'école et vous dénoncez
égalitarisme devons nous retenons aussi
une professionnelle aguerrie de la
chronique à chaque fois des avis
tranchés on retiendra votre coup de
gueule contre les donneurs de leçons sur
la guerre en ukraine j'espère
effectivement que bernard henri lévy que
glucksmann tous ces gens qui viennent
tous les jours nous faire elle sans la
télé en partie qui nous disent qu'il
faut aller faire la guerre pour aller
faire la guerre dans déjà qu'ils y
aillent un haut lieu de nous faire la
leçon sur les plateaux télé puisqu'il
nous parle de la guerre c'est des gens
qui nous ont invités à faire la guerre
en irak invités à faire la guerre en
afghanistan lé bien faire la guerre en
libye
[Musique]
pourquoi barbara lefebvre revenons à nos
moutons
quel est le programme idéal des français
trois domaines prioritaires d'après
votre enquête la sécurité l'économie et
le sanitaire une hiérarchie totalement
bousculés depuis la sortie de votre
livre car aujourd'hui les français
s'inquiètent surtout des prix à la pompe
et de la baisse de leur pouvoir d'achat
aggravée par la guerre en ukraine des
français qui reste quand même
préoccupées par l'urgence sécuritaire
face à la délinquance face au terrorisme
islamiste aussi des français qui font de
l'égalité une valeur totem à l'heure où
il constate une france fracturée car sur
les inégalités sociales
emmanuel macron a échoué dites vous et
le bilan est très sévère l'ensemble des
inégalités qu'elle soit sociale
sécuritaire scolaires sont considérés
comme étant aggravée depuis le début de
ce quinquennat plus de dépenses
publiques pour résorber les inégalités
plus de souverainisme économique et
écologique plus de référendum aussi pour
associer les citoyens aux décisions
c'est ce que réclament les français
selon vous alors barbara lefebvre dit
nous après avoir sondé vos concitoyens
c'est quoi être français en 2022 quel
président pourrait apaiser une france
fracturée quant à vous quelle étiquette
politique revendiquez vous nous
attendons vos réponses
alors on va y répondre dans cet
entretien bonsoir barbara lefebvre soit
et merci d'être là alors justement avant
de rentrer dans le détail des résultats
de votre enquête pour commencer je
voulais vous poser la question de votre
dédicace vous dédiez se livrent à la
france du 17 novembre 2018 la france dé
gilet jaune pourquoi la france dé gilet
jaune des ronds points c'est-à-dire 7,7
france qui effectivement s'est soulevé
d'une façon assez étonnante pour
d'ailleurs beaucoup de sang d'heure pour
aussi beaucoup de de nos élus nos
dirigeants qui ont été un petit peu
surpris effectivement par cet élément
déclencheur de la taxe carbone mais
comme toujours dans les les les
soulèvements populaires les révoltes
c'est un élément un grain de sable dans
la machine qui fait fait l'éruption mais
il est pour le feu lire ce livre on va
était assez con presque entendue pour la
crise des gilet jaune a été une crise
très marquante du quinquennat ça n'a pas
été la seule il ya eu des crises subi la
crise sanitaire c'est pas quelque chose
que le président macron a déclenché mais
cette crise et gilet jaune il à la
république en marche a souvent tendance
à la présenter comme étant une crise qui
lui est arrivé par le hasard des choses
mais en réalité cette crise là elle
vient s'inscrire dans à la fois elle
prend ses racines aussi dans le
quinquennat précédent de françois
hollande qui a beaucoup déçu les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes en
difficulté et pour qui l' ascension
sociale et l'ascension républicaine et
est en grande difficulté et emmanuel
macron faisait partie de ce gouvernement
de françois hollande on a souvent
tendance à l'oublier il a été le
ministre de l'économie qui a fait des
lois qui ont été des lois qui ont été
perçus par les classes populaires comme
des lois très dur donc cette crise et
gilet jaune à mon sens elle a été très
marquante ça a été un tournant du
quinquennat mais c'est aussi un tournant
pour les français parce que les français
se montrait là aussi leur goût de la
politique la politique au sens noble du
terme alors je mets fiance à l'égard des
politiciens mais leur goût invétéré de
la politique est aussi leur croyance
dans la puissance de la politique a
changé les choses justement parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de résultats qui font écho à
ce mouvement alors peut-être sur la
démarche je précise tout de suite que
c'est une enquête nationale qui a été
réalisée en septembre dernier à la
rencontrer avant que les prix du gaz et
du carburant n'explose et donc avant que
le pouvoir d'achat ne s'installe comme
la priorité des priorités des français
c'est le jeu d'une enquête qui est faite
à l'instant t expliquez-nous votre
démarche pourquoi barbara lefebvre vous
faire un grand sondage en s'appuyant sur
l'ifop alors des sondages sur les
attentes des français y en a tous les
jours dans tous les médias les sondages
en général sont ciblées sur certaines
attentes on va faire d une enquête sur
la sécurité ou alors on va aussi parfois
simplement commandé une enquête sur une
question l'interdiction du voile eux
enfin voila vous on va faire des
questions très précises et justement
l'instant tu es là l'idée c'était
d'essayer de de décrire le programme
idéal des français à l'orée de cette
présidentielle parce que la course des
petits chevaux l' hyper personnification
c'est la spécificité de la proche alors
voilà l'aspect si la foule qui avait
conçu les questionnements qui est
construit le questionnaire frédéric dabi
de l'ifop l'a relu la retravailler pour
laure le faire entrer véritablement dans
la méthodologie habituelle des sondages
et en particulier de ceux conduits par
l'ifop qui sont très expert en la
matière c'est donc plus d'une vingtaine
de questions qui sont des questions
concrètes avec des mesures que les
françaises soit souhaiterait voir mis en
oeuvre est évidemment dans les
propositions de mesures je me suis
attaché à ce que tout le champ
idéologique politique soit représentée
pour permettre aux français de toute
opinion puisque d'ailleurs ils pouvaient
cocher plusieurs cases en même temps
parce que pourrait avoir version voilà
les trois les trois principales mesures
par exemple et il s'en dégage est
effectivement une certaine cohérence
mais alors justement on va essayer on
pourra pas tout dire nous on va essayer
de donner un peu le le portrait du port
du programme idéal à leurs yeux d'abord
ce qu'on découvre c'est qu'il ya un
décalage entre la parole publique et la
parole médiatique et les attentes
concrètes des français si vous deviez au
fond illustré de manière la plus
frappante à travers les résultats de
cette enquête ce décalage là ce serait
sur quoi le décalage par exemple assez
sur l'importance de la question de
l'identité la question civilisationnel
auprès des français on l'a vu septembre
octobre novembre les médias se sont
passionnés pour les le débat
civilisationnel porté par eric zemmour
qui en plus a fait un petit peu attendre
tout le monde avec cette soi-disant
candidature sur laquelle tout le monde
se poser des questions et donc il a
laissé entendre qu'il avait posé la
question centrale qui était au coeur de
la campagne n'est pas le cas du tout ce
n'est absolument pas le cas c'est à dire
que les questions du quotidien sont les
questions prioritaires pour les français
je vous l'avais dit c'était la sécurité
en septembre venait ensuite le pouvoir
d'achat la question de la santé puisque
on était encore dans la crise sanitaire
et l'environnement en revanche les
questions qui sont des questions plus
abstraites comme le fonctionnement
démocratique comme l'identité où le
pouvoir des médias ce sont des questions
qui viennent à la fin et l'identité même
et avant dernière dans l'ordre de
priorité des français et donc on voit là
un certain décalage ouais en train une
eau moore à 13 ans avec sa crise dans la
réalisation évidemment non seulement il
a un petit peu tout faux ça veut pas
dire que les français ne sont pas
inquiets les français sont inquiets
d'ailleurs dans l' enquête ils disent
que il y a une problématique avec
l'islam qui pourrait effectivement avoir
des pans de son action politique qui
sont incompatibles avec la république
donc il ya une
certaine inquiétude des français nés en
manquez pas ce n'est pas absolument pas
leur priorité et en cela d'ailleurs la
fin de sa campagne le montrent les
français ont décroché complètement sur
ce sujet alors on va parler de la
dépense publique c'est intéressant parce
que vous relevez que les français
veulent beaucoup plus d'investissements
dans les services publics éducation
santé hôpital justice donc est ce que
c'est le quoi qu'il en coûte qui est
passée par là est ce que c'est le retour
de l'état providence ou est-ce qu'au
contraire c'est le fait qu'il n'ait pas
tenu ses promesses qui fait qu' il ya
plus le choix là maintenant il faut
réparer les français sont très attachés
au service public du quotidien
c'est-à-dire ses services publics dont
ils ont compris qu'ils sont les premiers
bénéficiaires mais qui sont aussi les
premiers contributeurs parce que les
français en tout cas ce qui ressort de l
enquête c'est qu'ils ont sentiment
qu'ils sont ceux qui participent à
travers leurs impôts directs et
indirects au financement des de la
dépense publique et ils sont aussi ceux
qui en bénéficient à travers l'école
l'hôpital public la police la justice et
ils ont ri sont pas dupes mais ils sont
pas dus ils veulent maintenant des
résultats sur les services qu'ils ont le
sentiment que cette tuyauterie immense
que représentent les services publics
sont plein de petits trous et que
l'argent en réalité 28 ça fuite partout
et ils ont conscience aussi que les
petites rustine qu'on a mis jusque là et
notamment la principale qui est
d'injecter encore plus d'eau dans l'est
dans les tuyaux percés ça ne fonctionne
pas parce que c'est beaucoup de dépenses
le quoi qu'il en coûte ça a été beaucoup
de dépenses mais finalement assez
possible et avec plein de fuite et donc
il ya une volonté à la fois de restaurer
ceux-ci services publics et en
particulier d'être sur l'humain c'est à
dire investir dans des fonctionnaires
mais des fonctionnaires de terrain c'est
à dire mais des enseignants des
gendarmes des policiers plus de soignant
à l'hôpital c'est à dire qu'en réalité
les français comprennent qu'il ya des
économies à faire et ce sont des
économies notamment de structures dans
cette administration administrante comme
je crois la 10è valérie pécresse même si
elle était un peu flou sur les contours
mais les français en ont véritablement
conscience et ils sont aussi très
respectueux de ses fonctionnaires
c'est-à-dire de ces petits
fonctionnaires qui gagne peu et qui
d'ailleurs pour certains se sont trouvés
d'ailleurs très solidaire de cette
france des gilet jaune et des raies
alors justement il ya un mot qui revient
aussi souvent il ya celui de
souveraineté on va en parler mais il les
inégalités qui se sont creusées ça il ya
quasi unanimité au fond qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent plus de justice sociale ou
est-ce que c'est toujours les missions
de l'état ces fameux service public
qu'il faut absolument remettre sur les
rails alors ce qui est vrai pour les
inégalités le président idéal des
français en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est un président qui doit
s'attacher à réduire les inégalités à
réduire cette fameuse fracture dont
parlait déjà jacques chirac et que tous
les présidents à la suite ont invoqué
mais n'ont jamais réduite et sur les
l'accroissement des inégalités selon
emmanuel macron le bilan est extrêmement
sévère je ne m'attendais d'ailleurs pas
à ce que les français soient aussi dur
il ya que surligner les inégalités
hommes-femmes ou les français prennent
acte d'un des cinq ans d'avancé ce qui
est vrai marlène schiappa notamment été
très active et très visible aussi dans
ce domaine mais pour tout le reste les
français sont très sensibles notamment
aux inégalités scolaires ils ont le
sentiment que les enfants de milieux
populaires et des petites classes
moyennes réussissent moins bien à
l'école et quand l'ascenseur social est
bloqué dès l'école c'est une société
bloquée dans son ensemble est sacré
énormément de stress chez les français à
tout prix la du stress dont on parlait
de la souveraineté alimentaire tout le
monde parle de la souveraineté on est un
tournant quand même dans les dents cette
présidentielle souveraineté industrielle
souveraineté énergétique ça vous le
saluer est ce que ça vous ça vous
réjouit que ça y est on en est là
maintenant je ne sais pas si je
m'en réjouis parce que comme c'était
évoqué dans le plateau précédent
beaucoup de gens parlent de souveraineté
voire de souverainisme sans vraiment
savoir ce qu'ils mettent derrière parce
que la souveraineté c'est pas seulement
effectivement comme ça a été dit
précédemment l'autonomie c'est aussi la
capacité à se gouverner soi même or dans
bien des domaines nous sommes dépendants
on l'a vu même par exemple l'état lui
même et peut être dépendant de cabinet
de consulting donc voilà donc à partir
de ce moment là on est vraiment
dépendant du privé par exemple même dans
la capacité de l'état à prendre des
décisions et à décider delà de sa propre
politique donc on voit effectivement
chez tous les candidats aujourd'hui est
par exemple pour emmanuel macron c'est
particulièrement piquant de voir ce
retournement de situation invoquer
effectivement la souveraineté même si
pour lui c'est plus souvent la
souveraineté européenne que la
souveraineté nationale ça s'appelle 2022
les français ont choisi grande enquête
nationale chez plon vous découvrirez
d'une certaine façon le portrait robot
idéologique du président ou de la
présidente qui se dessine en creux il
doit être républicain je le dit laïc il
doit avoir une conception de la nation
ouverte accueillante mais défenseur vous
l'avez compris de la souveraineté des
plus mauvaises modeste et lutter contre
les inégalités oui non d'où vous parlez
de la droite de la gauche c'est pas
votre sujet non c'est vraiment paoloni
le droit aux mêmes vins de cépages et
certaines fois et je n'ai pas les
réseaux sociaux mais parfois on me
traite de mélenchonistes d'autres fois
on me on me dit proche du rassemblement
national dont je crois que c'est
simplement de regarder la france en face
et de voir qu effectivement c'est enjeu
de souveraineté sont des enjeux majeurs
aujourd'hui et surtout cet attachement
des français pour l'égalité pour la
réduction des inégalités économiques qui
sont particulièrement seyante merci
beaucoup barbara lefebvre vous rester
avec moi c'est lors du scan on est à
onze jours seulement du premier toi
regarde
mais avant l'été il y a les deux bras de
fatalité au grand remplacement et bien
molle vous propose le round mort d'agir
pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
bose exclu il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur caritas a pas de mystère c'est
le vol
et je sais du sur ce plateau market
darrigrand sémiologue qui s'est
intéressé ce soir à une grande absente
dans la campagne l'écologie elsa monde
un gain vad la rédaction de lcp bonsoir
on s'arrête ce soir sur une audition
très importante celle des deux chefs de
la prison d'arles dans laquelle s'est a
été assassiné yvan colonna même si c'est
lié à la campagne présidentielle on le
verra et stéphane pour ouvrir le bal
stéphane blakowski votre carnet de
campagne campagne l'oeil de blacko alors
sur cassure quoi votre oeil a été
attirée ce soir voyez là c'est moi là
bas on y va alors aujourd'hui journée de
chat j'ai passé ma journée à examiner un
trou de souris mais pas n'importe lequel
le fameux trou de souris par lequel jean
luc mélenchon espère se faufiler
jusqu'au second tour et après tout
pourquoi pas c'est une partie des
électeurs de jado roussel hidalgo voter
mélenchon bas la gauche pourrait
peut-être affronter macron le 24 avril
c'est pas impossible d'ailleurs cette
tentation on voit qu'elle existe
regardez dans les sondages sa mesure la
certitude qu'ont les électeurs de voter
pour leurs candidats dont vous voyez ce
qu'ils sont bottes macron le panier
zemmour sont vraiment bien décidés à
voter pour leur candidat en revanche les
éditeurs hésitent ce qui pourrait
changer d'avis c'est justement ce qui va
troussel hidalgo et jadot donc là c'est
bon pour jean luc mélenchon mais moi je
me disais la même chose que vous ben
c'est une question de génération je
pense qu'on la rencontre on a encore en
tête les vieux concepts droite gauche
qui veulent plus dire grand chose
d'ailleurs parce que franchement on se
dit jadot il est de gauche mais non je
préviens de gauche donc ils vont être
d'accord mais pas du tout mais alors
écoutez les différences que pointe
delphine batho entre son programme et
celui de mélenchon il y a des
différences majeures
entre
jean luc mélenchon et les positions
qu'il prend sur les énergies fossiles
sur poutine sur le fait d'heureux refusé
de le qualifier de dictateur et la
position qui est celle des écologistes
cela dit les électeurs ne suivent pas
toujours les consignes de vote les
candidats je vois ce que voulait dire
vous imaginez le peuple de gauche qui
les prenons conscience de cette chance
historique se mobiliseraient enfin
derrière un candidat qui amènerait à peu
de justice dans ce pays il est bien sûr
trop ce que le peuple de gauche c'est
plus ce que c'était myriam autres et ça
ça a changé tout ça aujourd'hui quand on
demande aux électeurs de jane do roussel
ou
hidalgo pour qui ils voteraient s'ils ne
votaient pas pour leur candidat favori
de lons au branchement quelque sorte les
électeurs de fabien roussel disent oui
mélenchon c'est notre deuxième choix
mais en revanche les lecteurs de jado
les électeurs disent à gogo un second
choix il voterait plutôt pour macro mais
c'est la fondation jean jaurès qui a
fait ce tableau est ce que vous croyez
vraiment à tout sous ces sondages qui
appuient votre démonstration alors là
vous êtes en train de basculer du côté
de d'anne hidalgo là je vous souhaite la
dernière nouvelle la proposition en tout
cas du socialiste c'est de supprimer
interdire les sondages mais oui quand on
est à 2 % d'intentions de vote est ce
qu'on a envie de le savoir on écoute les
glaciers il faut qu'ils aient une
période pendant laquelle les sondages ne
sont plus publiés parce que en réalité
ils matrice complètement notre façon de
penser et aujourd'hui on finit par
croire que si on vote pour untel ou
untel ça ne sert à rien et qui vaut
mieux voter pour tel ou tel vous voyez
ça tombe bien parce que justement dans
son programme jean luc mélenchon c'est
exactement la même proposition qui
propose d'interdire les sondages avant
les actions dont ils sont d'accord là
dessus est bon mais non il a même dit
qu'ils étaient d'accord sur tout il
pourrait pas s'entendre à gauche c'est
ça qui est triste pourquoi est ce que
vous voulez dire par là qu'est ce que je
voulais dire par là je sais pas je j'ai
dû vouloir dire qu'en fait la gauche
retrouvée en miettes à la fin des
présidentielles et que le seul enjeu
l'application c'est d'abord qui va
ramasser la plus grosse part des miettes
aux législatives voilà donc par exemple
un milliard ou celle qui est assez franc
quand il parle il dit clairement qu'il y
pense déjà à l'après et d'ailleurs il va
tenir une place dans cette après la
présidentielle le 10 avril non seulement
ils peuvent voter pour leurs convictions
pour leurs idées mais ils peuvent aussi
voter pour l'avenir et pour la suite et
je vais vous dire une dernière chose moi
je n'ai pas envie d'être le grand chef
de l'opposition je veux être le grand
chef du rassemblement
le grog il a pris la confiance sa
famille cette campagne campagne qu'il a
fait non il voit bien comme le chef
gauche mais pourquoi pas un mélenchon
n'est plus tout jeune hollande va pas
rétabli social-démocratie d'un
claquement de doigts donc peut-être que
l'avenir de la gauche et le parti
communiste qui comme assez marrant mais
c'est possible d'un mot le vote utile à
gauche quand vous entendez un peu les
candidats ça correspond un peu aux
attentes des français ou alors ils vont
bien compris c'est vrai que là quand la
campagne de fabien roussel est assez
étonnante néanmoins on voit bien que les
français restent très attachés à des
figures qu'ils connaissent et en
particulier à ces figures qui ont
labouré le terrain pendant ces cinq
années et il est vrai que les deux
grands concurrents les deux grands
opposants
h24 des masses a été jean luc mélenchon
et marine le pen est quelque part ces
deux personnages la récolte aujourd'hui
les fruits de leurs à une forme de
cohérence analogique pendant cinq ans
elle zappe alors on s'arrête ce soir sur
une audition très attendue elle avait
été reportée d'ailleurs elle a eu cet
après midi les chefs d'établissement de
la prison d'arles là où yvan colonna a
été assassiné que faut-il en retenir
bien écouter déjà ils étaient 2 myriam
corinne publié régniez marc collier elle
était en poste jusqu'à la fin février
2022 et lui il est arrivé le 1er mars la
veille de l'agression a dit yvan colonna
première question par posée par beaucoup
de députés comment deux détenus dps
détenu particulièrement surveillé eh
bien on pu tout simplement se retrouver
dans la même pièce ensemble et sans
surveillance écoutez la réponse de
corinne publièrent unis
une mesure de séparation alors eu du
sens si on avait eu la moindre
information le moindre indice le moindre
doute sur une
une difficulté entre entre entre ces
deux personnes mais ce qui n'était
absolument pas le cas quand je veux dire
c'est monsieur monsieur colonna
et l'ong ab se fréquenter autre question
posée celle des caméras de surveillance
dont conseil il ya eu une opération de
maintenance pile poil pendant cette
agression mais de toute façon ça
n'aurait rien changé puisque d'après le
chef de la prison derrière 46 caméras à
l'intérieur trois dômes extérieur il est
donc impossible de tout surveiller et on
s'oriente plutôt vers les zones
identifiées comme à risque comme les
retours de promenade on a interrogé les
débutantes interrogé marc ollier sur le
mobile franck est longue à b dit avoir
tué yvan colonna car ils auraient
blasphémer bien lui n'y croit pas du
tout écouter
qu'est ce qu'ils pouvaient faire pour
être connu et pas être le le petit
djihadistes inconnus parmi x centaine en
france agressé un surveillant le tuer il
ya déjà eu des tentatives de meurtres
des médias a nourri par les deux ou
trois jours agressé le directeur
possible on aurait passant par les trois
ou quatre jours et sinon qui le plus
connu sur la prison yvan colonna que
colonna et place fait mieux ou pas peu
importe qui lui ai dit dieu colonna
aurait dû aussi le choix je pense que
c'est vrai si dieu existe et il y aurait
pas la guerre
excusez moi c'est pas crédible c'est pas
crédible
donc il voulait se payer quelqu'un de
connu il s'est expliqué de son émotion
ce qu'il a vu les vidéos et puis il est
intervenu sur les lieux alors comment
ont réagi les députés convaincu par ces
explications pas pas vraiment beaucoup
d'interrogations qui sont restés
notamment sur le profil de franck est
longue à b on l'a dit dps détenu
particulièrement signalé comme l'a
corrigé à stéphane mais aussi this pour
terroristes islamistes comment at-il pu
devenir auxiliaire au sein de sa prison
et puis les députés élus de corse ou
originaires de corse eh bien ils ont des
doutes comment est-ce que c'est un
hasard complexe être victime la victime
s'appelle yvan colonna il n'en sont pas
si sûrs écoutez nous sommes là pour
traiter de la possibilité d'une
préméditation
mais aussi la possibilité que 1/3 et
plus commandité cet assassinat on se
demande même s'il n'est pas venu exprès
pour finir si il a mis la panique dans
toutes les prisons où ils étaient ils se
calment arles il approche colonna il se
fait nommer il arrive à se faire nommer
dans la salle
et à la fin ils le tube algérie voilà il
parle de zones d'ombré encore autour de
cette affaire je peux vous dire qu'il ya
une enquête judiciaire évidemment qui a
été qui a été ouverte j'ai pas le temps
de vous interroger je sais que c'est un
sujet qui vous tient à coeur mariette ce
soir une absente on l'a dit où est
passée l'écologie dans cette campagne
oui c'est vraiment une question qu'on
peut se poser il ya deux grandes
questions qui travaille beaucoup la
société et en particulier les jeunes
générations c'est le féminisme d'une
part d'autre part d'écologie or banos
nos candidats n'en parle pas beaucoup en
tout cas il n'y a pas d'affrontement
même sur le nucléaire par exemple qui
est un thème traditionnel de l'écologie
il n'y a pas du tout de nouveautés les
nouveaux métiers les nouveaux matériaux
des maisons etc c'est quand même très
curieux
donc tout se passe un peu comme si
l'écologie était diluée elle est un peu
partout dans les programmes mais du coup
elle est un peu nulle part alors ça se
voit beaucoup quand on quand on regarde
les affiches de campagne on a
l'impression que certaines ont mis un
petit brin de basilic sur l'or mais que
le véritable le plat de résistance
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout cette
question doit c'est probablement le
pouvoir d'achat ou donc la fin du mois
plus que la fin du monde alors quand on
regarde les affiches de campagne par
exemple celle de yannick jadot qui est
le plus vert ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'il n'a pas pris le verre de la
nature ce ver là c'est un verre de la
peinture il est repérable c'est de faire
du peintre véronèse c'est un verre
culturel c'est très curieux ça m'a
beaucoup frappé alors même que le ver
bas de de la nature quand elle s'éveille
au printemps l'herbe le veille de
l'herbe le verbe est le vert de la terre
vivant aulas il est à la fois réel et
éminemment symbolique ce vert printanier
donc je trouve ça un peu un peu curieux
que ce soit totalement absents alors du
coup bas tout est pris aujourd'hui dans
le bleu général le bleu de l'institution
le bleu qui représente
traditionnellement le roi et la vierge
c'est le pouvoir de voitures voilà donc
là c'est plutôt le droit d'y volume
bleus sont vraiment la droite ces bleus
là
on touche a disparu autant que
voilà on est dans cette espèce de bleu
si vous voulez régalien
qui a pris le verre il ya très très peu
de vert un petit fond utiliserait donc
ça me faisait penser puisque je suis
originaire du sud-ouest au rayon vert
qui s'enfonce dans le dans l'océan le
grand bleu on en vendant ses couleurs
symboles voilà au delà de l'écologie
c'est une couleur symbolique extrêmement
forte alors tout le monde sait que le
vert c'est l'espoir c'est tous les
enfants savent ça et en politique en
particulier en effet c'est l'idée d'un
monde un monde meilleur alors ça vient
d'un mot latin le vert viry douce en
latin vie reid en ancien français qui ne
veut pas dire la couleur qui veut dire
un élan de la nature un élan du corps
une vigueur si vous voulez donc c'est
une manière d'être devant devant la vie
devant les événements du coup le
printemps lui même est une manière
d'être enthousiaste d'être dynamique ça
s'appelait la reverdie et le printemps
vient de sa printemps arabe en politique
printemps rampe de mai 68 printemps de
la renaissance il ya une vitalité un
petit mot pour terminer rapidement dans
notre histoire aussi le verre
l'importance exactement le michel
pastoureau qui est le grand historien
des couleurs nous a expliqué que le 12
juillet 1789 le jeune avocat journaliste
camille desmoulins pour mobiliser la
foule et lui me lui promettre un monde
meilleur qui arrivent là qui est comme
un printemps eh bien il prend une petite
feuilles de tilleul et se le met à la
boutonnière et ça devient la cocarde des
révolutionnaires mais quand dans pendant
quelques heures en fait et puis
évidemment le bleu blanc rouge arrive et
hop sever qui aurait pu être notre
drapeau pour signifier l'espoir d'un
monde meilleur et bien a disparu et
notre campagne aujourd'hui n'est
vraiment pas celle qui va le faire
revenir évidemment merci infiniment
mariette merci pour cette analyse la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand dans la
campagne présidentielle c'est sur lcp
danse avant-garde merci infiniment à
vous tous merci barba lefebvre 2022 les
français ont choisi c'est chez plon pour
mieux nous connaître en quelque sorte
merci à vous très belle soirée et à
demain
[Musique]